president Trump invited brutal Filipino
dictator or drag Oh Duterte to visit the
White House yeah yeah it's the first
time Trump has ever said the words
Rodrigo please come to America didn't
get to say that very often we got to get
more Rodrigo's in here president Trump
also said he would be honored honored to
meet North Korean dictator Kim jong-un
yeah no no Trump said he's my kind of
guy he's crazy he's overweight he has a
ridiculous haircut we should get
together it's time it's finally caught
in another interview President Trump
said he thinks the civil war could have
been prevented yeah
after hearing this John McCain said
trust me I did everything I could
[Applause]
I guess TV big news in TV it was
announced today that Kelly Ripa's new
co-host will be Ryan Seacrest yeah yes
Seacrest said Seacrest was relieved he
said those twenty minutes he wasn't on
television with the scariest of his life
he has curry has he ever been gone I
don't think so no he's constantly been
on TV since he was a fetus
his first show who has hi I'm a fetus
you've probably all heard about that big
disaster the fire festival this weekend
did hear about this oh good you don't
need me the creators of fire festival a
luxury music festival that left
attendees on an island without adequate
food water shelter or medical care
they're all being sued for a hundred
million dollars yeah do you want to
attend the trial tickets start at $5,000
you gotta bring your own food the joke
there is it they charged a lot of money
for fire festival right so for them to
have a trial
yeah then charge a lot of money that's
just crazy okay
we're together for an hour and we need
to get along now we do remember all that
Conan Conan a couple of minutes ago and
the wounds where the hell's that
no you were right the first time the
joke was the problem should really
really have more confidence in
yourselves here's a weird story you're
gonna like this one
a Vermont candy maker yeah they have
candy makers in Vermont a Vermont candy
maker is hiding three golden tickets in
its chocolate bars and whoever finds
them is gonna win free parking yeah this
is of course inspired by that classic
children's story Charlie and the
municipal parking ordinance and there is
some I gotta mention this because this
is a story that is out there and it
could happen as you may have heard all
of the television writers including ours
might go on strike at midnight tonight
that could happen so there's a chance
that tomorrow my writers will spend all
day dressed like slobs and downloading
porn and that's if there's not a strike
that's the wooing no it's really not
good you're upsetting the old people
that watch why are they making the
noises on this show that's my parents by
the way when you come out there's too
much noise I love you my dad
you